this act that you guys have evolved into
could only happen between two great
friends i am just tickled when you guys
are on talk shows together and you start
going back and forth and there these
great lines about uh steve ping i forget
what the hell was it the show is like
steve at the urinal it streams for 35
minutes
i mean
these are fantastic how much time do you
guys spend thinking about each other and
writing um uh horrible things about each
other how does it work from a technical
standpoint you know we used to have a
joke that you know we we tried it on tom
hanks and he said oh my god that is so
so
funny and the joke was this
i would open with it i say i love
working with marty on stage because he
understands the concept of 60 40.
now tom hanks is like laughing instead
of and we used it like three times and
it just didn't play like we thought it
would marty you say hanging out with
steve is like deliverance because it's
all fun and games until the banjos come
out that that line is so great i mean
the back and forth between you two this
bromance whatever it is that's going on
even
i hate to hear that but go ahead but it
is a bromine you two have never seen
each other nude or have you um i'm i've
not not from the waist up
i've only i've only seen marty nude
through peepholes
you in touch with lauren steve oh yeah
is he a better friend to you than marty
or is marty your best friend well i see
marty moore lauren is very very busy
yeah who was the best man at your
wedding
was it was it you no it was lauren
[Music]
[Laughter]
i was a bridesmaid